♪ ♪
>> Tucker: PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED THIS AFTERNOON THAT HE
WILL BE PULLING THE
UNITED STATES OUT OF THE IRANIAN
NUCLEAR DEAL OF THREE YEARS
AFTER PRESIDENT OBAMA NEGOTIATED
IT.
THE PRESIDENT'S PROMISE TO KILL
THE STEEL FOR A LONG TIME.
HE TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
HE WON THE ELECTION, SO NO ONE
SHOULD BE SURPRISED THAT HE DID
IT.
IT WAS NEGOTIATED BY THE WAY BY
TWO GROUPS, IRAN AND THE OBAMA
STATE DEPARTMENT, NEITHER OF
WHICH HAD AMERICA'S INTEREST AT
HEART.
IT'S HARD TO FEEL TOO SAD ABOUT
THE DEATH OF THE DEAL.
STILL YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHAT IT
MEANS, WILL IT TAKE AMERICA
CLOSER TO A WAR WITH IRAN, AND
IF IT DOES ARE WE PREPARED TO
FIGHT THAT WAR, OR DOES IT MAKE
LASTING PEACE MORE CERTAIN?
MICHAEL ANTONE WAS A NATIONAL
SECURITY OFFICIAL IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
HE HAS JUST RAN TO THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THINKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: CERTAINLY NO
DEFENSE OF THE DEAL, WHICH I
TOOK AS A MATTER OF FAITH WAS
NEGOTIATED IN BAD FAITH AND NOT
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN VOTERS.
YOU'VE GOT TO KIND OF WONDER,
AMBASSADOR BOLTON GOES INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY THERE'S A MISSILE
STRIKE AGAINST SYRIA AND THE
IRAN DEAL IS SCUTTLED.
HE HAS SAID REPEATEDLY THAT HE
WOULD LIKE CONFLICT WITH IRAN.
THE QUESTION IS ARE WE MOVING
TOWARD THAT?